who the bedroom all round round now
can't wait in front of bedroom what
happened to the bedroom sink bedroom
sorry click the teddy bear
nothing out then click the boy wherever
it is painting and do that stop over
here can't look like it either
blanks nope I can't click [ __ ] it's
beautiful
I don't know the melody I shut up
not again what is it certificate she was
adopted well that explains how she's
[ __ ] up that was getting this game and
woodland or fringe December 24 1953 she
was prude she was improving me shut up
shut up no once you realize I hate her I
[ __ ] hate you let me look at you
[ __ ] you
ha clicking a million things the game
pick the daddy beer like a certificate
quick the collie thingy
Oh what is this she comes every night
she loves playing how does she I love
happy
although hanji he's really good in the
bed I mean in hiding I never find her
yeah stop doing that
got penis I said penis play with me oh
I'll play with you come here so
beautiful painting
I wish yous [ __ ] to move shut up I
don't want to play with you here [ __ ]
[ __ ] up now look at that light all the
way with her oh no I don't want to wait
[ __ ] boy
ah she tricked me the Oliv played well
look at that this is like a rope a thing
it's a graphics bug
it's supposed to be like that not
whatever this is
McDaniel's I need a [ __ ] Jack Daniels
oh good good perfect net new proof sweet
what is this what is this what is it why
are you hanging down there that's what
she said
with a bunch I'll set you geez
uh-huh
oh I can drag it that's why she said
that's a good well it doesn't make come
on light up my supposed to do with this
so weird activator
you really have to pay attention in
those games like tiny little details
everywhere
I think [ __ ] there you go we have for
now how will ready click to you what
else you want there's something I'm
missing
there it is ok birth registration no
this certificates certifies that
certified dois this certifies that a
certificate of birth has been filed with
state register vile that his recorder
name arena Road so I arena Halloween
Arutz born October 5 stuff interesting
not really I don't give a [ __ ] you're
working how's that I did that someone
working down there hello I want to go to
safe out
I have your certificate your acid not
sure what I'm gonna do with it acid oh
man you're so delicious are you doing
what are you sorry
what you doing you want acid
mr. Piggott here you go you can take it
I don't want it Oh Oh
scary scary let's just not touch your
boobs
yes you and me in the darkness mm-hmm
that was Susie hide it in the darkness I
don't to go to doctor you want from me
lady can just dangle there all day got
stuff to do
got a point even important person I
can't just stare at you all day don't
have time for this you an acid why do
you walk tell me tell me we're sorry
darkness on 30 that there's something
under the bed isn't it
main aim our memories man some sand some
really sorry it's glass broken glass
milk kissing no touch your boobs she
likes it apparently touch her whatever
no did nothing you want the acid huh you
want the certificate what sorry Suzie
she want me I haven't done anything
wrong
Oh what is that oh why thank you kind
sir
I'll be on my way now to the sacrum you
want a sin can I go please significant
maybe she wants to be alone with me
sometime or in the dark all right why do
you want I have the key for the safe
room but I can't stand to see you suffer
like that
mr. piece my poor child
I wonder how many times I click that did
not yeah
oh you're ugly tell me why ah yes you're
ugly I get it oh oh oh damn safe room
that sounds pretty [ __ ] nice look at
my boobs bottom seriously it's like oh
come on I saw that I thought I saw
anything is it right now I know it's the
it's code for I can go back and forth I
can't go back and bar man yes it was
like the year of birth maybe I think yes
okay I get it
let me just pick this she's on horny I
got it
daughter's girlfriend yes and it's like
in the bedroom I think I'm a genious
[ __ ] hate her so much
it's the tan 2463
I don't know the order it's [ __ ]
American we have different in Sweden
okay don't judge me wait it was December
the summer is 12 wow I'm a [ __ ]
okay no it's for oh that's a problem
wait it's a date of birth so you gotta
be 12 24 please work
no not work ah [ __ ] you
come on okay I'm cheating I'm cheating
mm-hmm I'm saying you have a problem
matter problem routine
okay I'm kidding
19:47 okay let's go
what I didn't cheat I fight figure that
out myself see I'm a genie why why I
have to die mom I want to leave no
matter what
aren't you a selfish bastard you're ugly
oh-oh-oh I can't we get up [ __ ] we're
not good I want to go oh I want to go
all the way
Oh No wow so chummy your face you're so
ugly I creaking her face I knew I was
gonna have it with though like new real
quick I don't want plays anymore Mouse
is a true story all photos and messages
are Ebola there's no intention to marry
Barbara a phony key let's go
special room no we're done we're done
we're definitely done thanks for
watching